this is a production of cornell
university
no problem and thank you for the the
lovely introduction and it's great to be
here and um
yeah i've always been fascinated with
how you turn jeans on and off and you
know my brief stint in industry you know
showed me the you know
what was going on with trying to
genetically engineer uh plants for the
field and now i'm still working in the
lab mostly with arabidopsis but i'm
hopeful that some of the tools that
we're building here will have
applications uh in the field in the
future and um so yeah
what are we doing so i'm trying to build
uh gene circuits but why are we doing
this so
as i'm sure i don't need to you know
tell most people probably in the
audience but um you know we've got
climate change today we've got a growing
population and a finite amount of land
so we really need to uh increase crop
productivity but in many cases uh we do
you know we've got stagnation in crop
yields and some of these factors are you
know
societal and economic but some of them
could be mitigated by improved uh
strains of plants being produced and so
we would like to use new techniques new
advanced ways of doing genetic
engineering to be able to achieve that
and so there are some grand challenges
out there that could really boost
productivity but they're going to
require a lot of work to achieve that
and more tools for better genetic
engineering so some of these uh you know
hopes for the future would be things
like nitrogen fixation in cereals so
only legumes uh
fix nitrogen through symbiosis with
bacteria now if we could get
legumes fixing nitrogen that could
really decrease the inputs required into
those crops and increase productivity
but
the
ability to do this
in nature for legumes requires a lot of
developmental biology signaling and
cooperation with bacteria
and that's multiple different things
that need to be altered
to allow
this nitrogen fixation trait and so we
need very sophisticated tools to
engineer that
in the another case would be c4 rice
as i'm sure many of you know there is a
c3 photosynthesis and then a more um
a more productive c4 photosynthesis
particularly at higher temperatures
and rice one of the major cereal crops
does not use uh sepal photosynthesis and
to engineer that into rice would require
both biochemical changes changes in
metabolism as well as developmental
changes and then also to separate the
the biochemical pathways into these
different cell types in a way that does
not occur naturally in rice which is c3
and so again we need really complicated
spatial temporal control over gene
expression now in development in normal
biology
we you know there are many different
factors that control where and when a
gene is turned on and off and you can
just see from these diagrams um here
that you know just the decision between
being a non
hair cell and a root hair cell in the
arabidopsis epidermis of the root
that's a really you know complex
decision with many different factors
different transcription factors and
other genes involved with that process
and a lot of regulation and
going over to humans and looking at
um some work from my time in berkeley
you know just looking at the number of
spicing factors in this in that interact
with each other uh you know this is a
massive amount of different interactions
for controlling gene expression that
happen both at the transcriptional level
and also at the post transcription level
so you know what hope do we have for
really and being able to engineer this
ourselves in plants for for custom
traits
well
at the moment we're quite limited by
what tools we have to genetically
engineer um plants so you know quite
often people rely upon the 35s promoter
which is a strong constitutive promoter
but sometimes you don't want to express
a gene at really high levels everywhere
in the plant
you know so there are other options out
there if you don't want to use 35s you
could use a slightly weaker modern tired
promoter like the acting tube promoter
you know that face a bit like me you
know based on the the fact that it's
gone midnight now um
but
you know again that's constitutively
expressed so it's expressed across the
whole plan so you may want to turn to a
stress-induced gene such as from heat
shock or
infection and these would allow for
condition specific responses
or you may want to turn to a cell type
specific promoter so you turn it on in
only one part of the plant based on a
developmental queue for example
or maybe you'll want a chemically
induced promoter such as using the decks
which we use often in the lab to
artificially induce gene expression so
we have these different options
but what happens if you wanted to
combine them what happens if you wanted
the high expression of 35s
with the stress response of a
virus induced promoter perhaps you also
want it only to be in one place
you know for example the root cortex
well it's very hard to engineer a
promoter with all of these features and
it's also very hard to identify a
promoter that naturally has all of these
features especially if you've got to do
it in every single crop
repeatedly and perhaps the promoter that
has these properties doesn't exist and
then if you decide oh this isn't what we
want we want it to be a more moderately
expressed promoter and we want it to be
the same cell location but now we want
it to be chemically inducible well now
you've got to start your search all over
again
and so this is where synthetic biology
comes in and hopefully we synthetic
biologists can
make it so that we have both we don't
have to choose between these different
properties but we can get cell type and
condition specific expression all
combined into one using what we call
gene circuits
so
how can we hope to achieve this well
we're hoping to achieve this with
something called boolean logic so
boolean logic is just a mathematical
framework for thinking about true false
binary data and you can think of it in
terms of this lovely venn diagram here
where you have
only green represented on where you have
both inputs turned on
so this could be demonstrated with a
simple electrical circuit such as here
where you need the complete circuit to
turn the light on and here we have two
switches once both are switched on the
light comes on we complete the circuit
and
this is very easy to visualize for
electronic circuit and we can also
visualize it with a symbol here and this
is the symbol for the and gate and here
is a truth table where we can see
the output is only on represented by one
and both of the inputs are on
in gene expression terms well you could
think of an and gate being you know
maybe there's a gene where you need two
different transcription factors to bind
before the transcription activates
so we can try to apply these
mathematical and electrical engineering
concepts to gene expression
and there are many different
logic gates that can exist so
in addition to the and gate where what
we effectively see is a restriction of
expression if we think about in terms of
gene expression this is restricting
where a gene is expressed based on the
activity of two factors whereas the or
gate is a really nice example because we
broaden the expression out you could
imagine that as two different
transcription factors and either could
express cause the expression of the
output gene
and then we can also use regression so a
nor gate is the opposite of an or gate
so it is on
unless you have one of the inputs
present so in this case you might think
of the inputs as being repressors such
as repressive transcription factors and
either one of them binding will turn the
gene off
so
in theory we can use these design
principles to try to design these things
but is this really relevant is it really
really realistic to do such a thing well
in nature we already see
expression pathways that look very much
like boolean logic gates
so if we go back to you know the
undergraduate class example uh the nobel
prize winning um lac operon for gene
regular you know understanding the gene
regulation that was very fundamental to
our understanding of
you know molecular biology
so in this pathway what we do is we have
lactose that effectively activates the
pathway and we have glucose that turns
it off but interestingly glucose
turns off the pathway even in the
presence of lactose not perfectly but
to a large extent
and so you can imagine uh this circuit
looking like this in terms of the venn
diagram so you only have output with
lactose but with glucose is present
it overrides it it's a dominant effect
it's a dominant negative effect it
overrides the activity of factors and
this looks like an a implied b logic
gate so we can build the sims draw the
symbol for that with lactose coming in
glucose overriding it we can draw the
truth table truth table sorry so we only
have lactose
by itself activating the output and even
if you have both it's um it is off this
is a generalization it's not perfect
so we can build simple uh you know
nature has built simple logical gates uh
already so it's not feasible that we can
try to engineer the same ourselves to
get more sophisticated control over gene
expression
now
the other thing is
is thinking about these things in a
digital manner on or off really a
realistic thing to do well
in plants we do have
binary systems so the
control of the floral developmental gene
flc
is controlled through an epigenetic
digital switch
so
uh
in this case you have a wild-type plant
where it's expressing flc and it does
not flap it flowers on a normal time
scale and then if you have the flc
mutant it will flow early
and the natural regulation of
flc
works where it progressively more and
more
genes more and more individual loci
epigenetically turn off
flc expression
as you go through winter and then that
gets
memorized during
the spring
so
you'll have warm temperatures where you
express flc as a floral repressor and
this delay is flowering
and then over time the exposure of cold
you will build up um the silencing at
each individual
loci so in a diploid cell each
individual gene copy is regulated
independently of each other and
eventually when you start to warm up you
then uh get that
memory state locked in
through the polygon repressive complex
mark
and so we know that digital switches can
exist in nature so when we were trying
to design our gene circuits we really
wanted to
look towards can we replicate it by a
binary digital system
for building these complex gates and so
we turn to
site-specific recombinases so these
recombinases recognize short sequences
about 35 base pairs
long and this is the frt
recombination target size sequence and
so this is set in the genome and all the
sequence in red between these two sites
could be a functional importance that we
want to conditionally remove so then
when we express the recombinase in this
case flp
we cut that bit of dna out so this
leaves one
frt
site in the genome and then all the
sequence in between them is now cut out
and become circularized and so
is not functional in any way that is
useful uh
and so we effectively remove it from the
system and now we it's not a scalar
system we do get left with a single
recombination target set
um but this
tool set of recombinases allows us to
try and build up a complex set of gates
and so the first simplest type of gate
is a simple yes gate a one input switch
so we go from
off to on as we express the recombinase
and so
in this case what we would do is we'd
have a constitutive promoter
driving a reported gene such as
luciferase or gfp
and we would use a terminator
in the what would normally be the five
prime uti region to turn this reporter
off so the promoter might be a
constituent promoter but it's no longer
able to express this reported gene we
flank this terminator with recombination
target sites and then only when we
conditionally express the recombinants
do we get that terminator removed and
the reported gene turned on
so
nice on paper very simple but first
we've got to build this system up we've
got to identify what promoters are
useful what terminators will function in
this way which recombinases will
actually work in our system
uh so you know there's a lot of steps
that need to be done to build this up so
we've moved to a protoblast system so
this is a
96 wall plate based proto plus system um
i found it incredibly reproducible which
i know a lot of
proto plus systems do have a an annoying
level of variability so i highly
recommend um checking out the protocol
that um adel khan a really talented
researcher in the lister lab
has shared online for this it took a lot
of optimization
and the way it works is we isolate
protoplasts from the leaves um so these
digest the cell walls away we release
the protoplasts and then we use peg to
transform our plasmid dna into them we
incubate them for you know one to
two and a half days and then we perform
a dual luciferase assay on them in a 96
wall plate format
and
uh the plasmids we transform in uh have
two different luciferase uh luciferase
genes so one encoding a ranilla
and this
is
reporting our output levels of our gene
circuit so this is the activity level
and then we have a normalizer this is
firefly and surprise our normalizer its
function is to account for variability
in protoplast survival in each well
transformation efficiency so by
normalizing the amount of vanilla over
the amount of firefly we're able to
see a
nice reproducible level of gene
expression so now comes to was actually
building and testing um the components
we need for gene circuits and the first
component we need really is a nice
terminator um to block expression of
renewable luciferase
so
as i just walk you through this first um
data slide
we have the acting two promoter driving
renewal with cipro's and this top
construct here
is our control construct it's our
constitutive renewal illusive pros and
this is our standard always-on plasmid
and so whenever you see a blue bar on a
graph
that is that control and so we use this
repeatedly as a way of like checking for
um
the standard level of expression we
would expect
and then we built variants of this
plasmid which have the fit recombination
sites but they also have different
terminators they have this synthetic
transcription block there's also the ocs
terminator a common terminator used in
plant biotechnology
there is also the
um a fusion of the two terminators as
some studies have shown that can enhance
termination terminator activity
we have the ocs variant which is
truncation of ocs we also have the
cauliflower mosaic virus terminator
another common terminator using plant
biotechnology and then we also use an
upstream open reading frame which has
been shown to cause uh rna decay in
transcripts from previous work that i
was involved with so we tested a range
of these in uh proto plus to see which
one inhibited expression the best and
while the transcription block and the uf
did it inhibits expression to some
extent it was not very impressive but
the ocs terminator and all its variants
did and so we've been able to turn our
gene expression off with ocs quite
effectively
to our surprise the cauliflower mosaic
virus uh terminator did not function
very well it did not inhibit gene
expression and at first this stumped us
but then um my phd student uh patrick
found this paper from over 30 years ago
where they'd actually done um a similar
experiment placing the cauliflower
mosaic virus at different
distances away from the promoter and
they found if it was close to the
promoter termination did not occur
and so it seems to be a location
dependent termination which is very
interesting from a mechanistic point of
view and also important for us to know
synthetic biologists that think you know
genetic components can be very location
and context specific and that's
something i think we as synthetic
biologists trying to build
you know engineer very complicated uh
pathways like this we need to keep that
in mind when we're building um
you know new uh plasmids and functions
into plants
so this was great we found a terminator
that can turn the expression off but for
our work in protoplasts what we would
like to do is have a promoter
constitutive promoter that we can
include into certain plasmids to show
the on state to represent the on state
and so we tested a range of different
promoters that could drive the
recombinase flp
in this system and compared it to the
expression of both the constitutive look
plasmid as well as our ocs terminator
so when we did that
we found that all the promoters we
tested nos
tctp acting 2 and 35s they all
did create what we call the yes gate the
one input switch and activate but only
the tctp did it to levels comparable to
our constitutive uh look so
uh that was really good you know it's
nice to see that our um
that we've been able to build a one
input
switch
um but we wanted to go back into stable
plants do this in whole organisms and
see how this behaves there and so we
built a one input
yes gate there and we use this time the
heat shock inducible promoter to drive
the expression of
the recombinants and for a reporter this
time we're using nuclear localized gfp
and as you can see without a heat shock
there are no nuclear
localized gfp in the roots but when we
do heat shock
the sister plants we see lots of gfp
accumulating in the nuclei across the
roots so this was great so we've got
the basic components we need to build a
one input switch
and
even work in viva with this so that's
great and then i got very excited i got
maybe a bit bold and thought oh well we
can finish this project off in a year
spoiler alert that didn't work that was
2019 when i thought that
so immediately i decided to jump into
building two input gates i thought well
we've got fop working we've got the
basic commands working i can just grab
the most commonly used recombinants in
all the biotechnology three
parts of the creelock system and just
use that as the second input with flp
it's guaranteed to work guaranteed to
work
sadly it didn't work
and this was really surprising so the
way that all gate was built
we use
we put the recombination target sites
for both flp and cree
surrounding
the ocs terminator so either recombines
can cut the ocs terminator out
and then for each of the plasma is
representing the one input stage we
included either fop or cree and we also
included a two input stage where
included both flp and cree
and
when we look at this plot you can see
again our positive control in blue our
off state in gray and then the expected
on states in green but only flp behaves
as expected so again we're seeing it
activate as we would
expect but cree one input does not it's
repressed still which is really
confusing
even more confusing is that the
inclusion of creon the plasmid also
inhibits the activity of flp
and so
it's taking uh the plasmid that did
previously have high recombination rates
and causing
you know uh no activity in terms of
vanilla expression so this was really
surprising and i think we're finally
close to figuring out the problem here
but
this this was a big shock for us so then
we started looking for alternative
recombinases to try and build up a two
input switch so we took that big step of
testing different one input yes gates
for another recombinase that could work
and so initially um my honor student
from 2020 um
florence did an amazing job of testing
lots of different uh recombinases uh
escri v crevica all of them are free
relatives um however none of them cause
activation
not anywhere near as impressive as the
actuation scene by fop so again this was
really surprising to us uh that none of
these behave the way we expected them to
so i
in parallel with this
was testing and cloning b3 which is a
relative of fop and when we tested it we
found that yes actually it behaves
almost the same as
flp
in the one input yes gate so
fantastic finally we found a recombinase
that can behave itself and work the way
we want it to
and start building the two input
switches
but
now i'm getting a bit of healthy
paranoia i'm thinking well maybe they're
relatives of each other maybe they
cross-react in animal cells they've been
shown not to cross-react but we've
always got to take the literature
published literature with a grain of
salt so i go ahead and test that and i'm
very happy to say there was no
cross-reactivity so when we put flp on a
plasmid with the b3 target sites there's
no activation and the same in reverse so
we get good activation uh of the
appropriate target sites but not with
the inappropriate recombination target
sites so this is great so now we can
finally go back to building those two
input
gates that we initially tried to build
so we went back to the or and now also
expanding out to the and gate
and so the and gate the all gate follows
the same design as with cree but now
with the b3 recombinators and target
sites so again either economies can cut
it out and the other difference to note
here is that
my paranoia was creeping in and so i
designed
an extra two input version plasmid where
i swapped the ordering of the input
genes around just in case that made a
difference it doesn't seem to make a
difference but again i think it's
important that we have as many different
controls for the context of um you know
the the components we're using in
synthetic biology as possible
and so for the all gate you know we see
that the zero input state is repressed
and all of the one and two input states
are expressed at least the same level as
the constitutive or higher so this is
wonderful we get all gate logic and this
is you know this is brilliant so then we
tried and gate
and the and gate works where we have two
copies of the ocs terminator
each one cut out by different
recompanies so now we need both
recombinases to be expressed
in order to activate renewal and you can
see here that
when we have the zero input state or the
one input states we have
no expression on very low expression of
granila luciferase but if we express
both of the recombinances suddenly we
get very high levels of vanilla
um after 24 hours it's still lower than
our control but by 48 hours it's at
comparable levels which is interesting
so it suggests that the
this reaction is slower than um the or
gate which might make sense because we
have two we need two different
recombination events to occur
on the same plasmid in order to get
activation um so it might be the
dynamics are different but it still uh
works so uh that's really good news so
then we wanted to take it back into
stable plants we wanted to see if we
could get an and gate to work
with um
you know
natural or you know relevant inputs to
switch between them so we created
another plasmid this time we're using
the 35s promoter
and again we've got
to the two different recombina
terminators each removed by different
recombinants we've got nuclear localized
gfp as the output we have a c-curve
marker for a selection of transformed
plants
we have a constitutionally expressed m
cherry that is also nuclear localized
and this will mark every nuclei in the
the plant
and the root is where we're looking for
expression it will mark every root
nuclei uh as
red with m cherry
then we used flp as one of the inputs
using the dex inducible promoter and
then we also used a cortex specific
promoter to induce b3
so we should only see expression of gfp
in the cortex after dex induction
and so you can see here with the solvent
control um
we have the bright field and gfp we see
no gfp nuclei however if we look where
we add
uh dex we do see uh many different
nuclei lighting up green
and if we look at the so i took a z
stack at the control call of these uh
multiple routes and he's a
representative where uh i also stained
with pi to outline the cell walls and so
you can see the on the outer layer you
have the epidermis the cortex you've got
these bigger rounder cells that
represent the cortex the second layer in
from the root and then you have the
epidermis and
you can't really see the steely in this
experiment
and you can see that the only
nuclei in this and other
um examples that lights up green is in
the cortex so this is wonderful so not
only do we only see expression of green
nuclei uh
observe green nuclei in the dex
treatment but they are also only in the
cortex so this is a functioning and gate
working in vivo so this gives us hope
for being able to move this and build
more circuits in stable plants which is
ultimately where we want to go working
in protoplast is a nice fast way of
screening lots of things and working out
what does work and what doesn't but
ultimately we do want to be working with
stable plants and potentially moving
into crops
so now we've got activation working
really really well
now can we deal with repression can we
turn off genes and so i tried to build
the nor gate
and so
this time to design a nor gate we don't
use a terminator in fact we want it to
be default on so therefore we want to
turn it off and in this case we were
removing the cds of renewable reciproce
with either b3 or flp
however when we actually did the
experiment we saw that the onsta the the
no input state was on as expected
and flp was able to turn it off quite
rapidly
but after 24 hours with b3 alone
it doesn't change it's not off
after 48 hours
we do get some decrease in expression
so
b3 seems to be acting very slowly it's
not very effective it's acting much
slower than flp
and at this point i took it quite
personally i'm sure b3 being a molecule
has no
motives to ruin my life but i took it
very personally because b3 had been the
savior it had rescued me from you know
pre-being a failure and so i was very
excited i thought we'd be smooth sailing
sadly that was not true so again i
relearned my lesson we've got to test
every component in isolation and look at
different contexts where it may or may
not work
so in this case
i isolated
um i made um not gates
where we just have uh
either frt sites or b3
rt sites to be recombined out
and we can see that
in the flp
even after 24 hours we get repression
but after 24 hours with the b3
there's no repression
mild repression after 48 hours slightly
better oppression after 64 hours so
just as we saw in the nor gate
when b3 is trying to cut out the vanilla
luciferase is cds
it's not behaving itself very well it's
very slow it's very inefficient
and so i thought well what could
possibly be going wrong is it the
sequence
um
itself is it something to do with uh
the distance between the recombination
sites so in the terminator example the
recombination sites were 700 base pairs
away from each other in this case
they're 2kb away from each other so is
there a way we could uh
turn the gene off by removing a smaller
region
and the acting tube promoter used in
these constructs is only 800 base pairs
so very similar in size to the
terminator that b3 was very good at
removing so i redesigned the constructs
to target the promoter region and for
both fop and b3
circuits we see good um depression even
after 24 hours so again another really
great
example of context specific
activity so you know synthetic biology
we need to test parts we need to explore
things in detail
so
now we've got this working what i wanted
to do next was to combine
activation and repression into the same
circuit so this was going after the a
implied b
so by going after the a implied b
uh
circuit
um the way this would work is that the
zero input state would be off because we
still have the ocs terminator in the
five prime utr
if we activate flp only we can remove
this ocs terminator and that's exactly
what we see we see activation when we
activate fop
but then if we activate b3 or b3 and flp
what we do is we remove the actin 2
promoter so it doesn't matter if the
terminator is removed because if the
promoter is removed you're never going
to get expression of our look
so and that's exactly the behavior that
we saw so this was a really wonderful
experiment and showed that we're able to
build these more complicated circuits
that integrate both activation and
repression into it and replicate you
know
expression uh patterns similar to what
we see in the lac operon and potentially
in other places in nature so
um we've been able to build these more
complicated circuits but there's still a
lot to do and one of the things that we
looked at next was
can we
using just one recombinase expand our
toolkit for the circuits further and so
with flp we it's already published um a
split site where you can split flp into
two inactive components and then
dimerized to bring them back together
and so this is the crystal structure of
flp binding to dna
and then what we did was we split it at
a known split site and here
alpha fall 2 generated models of what
these would look like and so we have one
fragment um you know very large fragment
one of fop with the link the c1
homodymerization domain from phage and a
nuclear localization signal and then we
also have the other part of fragment of
flp and much shorter one
the linker uh the nuclear localization
scenario in the c1 and my diarization
domain so if expressed by themselves
neither one can cause activation neither
one will cause recombination
however if you express them both in the
same cell at the same time
they will reconstitute and form a
new
um
a new active recombinase and are able to
activate and so
we put this to the test to try and build
what we call a split and gate
and so
um
florence my amazing honor student she
was able to
build and test this and so you can see
here you just need one terminator site
so this reduces the size of the
constructs
and you're able to remove this ocs
terminator only when you have both parts
of the recombinase expressed in the
sample so this is wonderful
uh and one of the advantages of
this would be if you imagine you had one
of your inputs where it's only expressed
every the root but the other one might
be induced by heat shock so that would
be induced across the whole plant
but what happens if you wanted to get
seeds from that plant plant and grow
them in the next generation without the
surface already being triggered with a
traditional
and gate approach it would already be
partially triggered by the heat shock
because i would
recombine that one of the two
terminators in this case you would never
have the aerial tissue
have recombination events because you
need both recombinases be expressed at
the same time in the same place so for
certain circuit applications where you
won't have expression in the shoe
typical meristem you would be able to
save seeds from the next generation so
we think this could be a very useful
modification to the system
additionally
we also built a nand gate which um
um
was really great and so florence
actually she was bought after honors and
decided before she went to start a job
to come back into the lab
which um amazed me uh i was still on
christmas break when she came back in um
but she came in and she pushed this
forward and designed a nand gate and so
the nine gate would cut out the promoter
but only when both halves are expressed
and this is exactly what we see we see
good levels of expression
except for when we express both halves
other companies so now we can get an and
nand gate logic using these um
recombinases so i think this this
is a great example of how we can expand
out the toolkits and at the moment we're
doing research on how to do this further
and create more split recombinases as
well as uh you know bring other
recombinases like create back into
our toolkit and be able to make much
more complicated complex circuits with
more than two inputs
um but yeah so just before i wrap up the
talk i did want to talk a bit about the
growing field of
plant gene circuits in general so
we've had a few publications this year
uh on planching circuits so um uh jen
brophy at stanford uh led this amazing
study published in science where they
created um
synthetic genetic circuits implants uh
using uh
bacterial transcription factors and so
they're able to make a wide array of
different uh logics uh by combining
different bacterial transcription
factors both activators and repressors
implants
and so
the advantage of this system and other
systems like it would be unlike my
recombination based system
these would be reversible
so the advantage of a recombination
based system is that once the
recombination event happens it is a
stable locked-in change and so if you
require that memory of the event
then recombination circuits are going to
be very valuable so for example you know
a dream scenario would be if you know a
farmer predicted like a particular
disease or environmental stress was
coming towards their field if they had
time they could potentially spray their
field
but with a reversible circuit based on
transcription factors
the timing of that would be very key
and might be very difficult to achieve
whereas with the recombination based
circuit you might be able to
prime the plants ahead of the incoming
stress
so that would be one of our hopes for
how we could use this technology in the
future
but
my my recombination based circuits are
not reversible and so if reversibility
is something important then these sorts
of circuits would be very important
uh based on artificial transcription
factors and so another um paper that's
come out of the the lister lab um led by
you know really great adult town um
is a crispr interference based gene
circuit and so that's going through peer
review at the moment um but because i
think it's such a really interesting
system i just want to take a moment to
um
walk you through the basics of it so
the way this system works is that um you
built a nor gate
um
using a synthetic promoter and so this
promoter has had two artificial
single guide irony binding sites
introduced to it
and if you express one or both of the
single guide rnas
then the crispr
dcas9 protein is able to bind
and because it's binding at a key part
of the promoter this
blocks expression of the output gene
and so when this was tested um it worked
as hoped so there's a range of different
synthetic promoters that adele has uh
created for this
and you can turn off vanilla
using um them and so again it replicates
the nor gate logic
but one of the beautiful things about
the nor gate is that it is a universal
gate and so you can layer them on top of
each other and achieve any of the basic
boolean
uh gate
output you know combinations and so for
example um the
computer that took
people to the moon
had
maybe 5 000 nor gates building of that
computer and so
and that achieved all the basic
computation processes that you would
need to do such a complicated uh
achievement
and so
what adele did was he took
different nor gates that he built and
laid them on top of each other and so by
combining two in this format you're able
to achieve a nor gate and get or gate
logic
whereas
combining them in this combination
you're able to achieve an a implied b
logic
and so i just think that this is a
really nice elegant system um that is
very modular so that
each guide rna is you know very small so
the inputs are very small compared to my
very bulky recombinase
genes
so you know it's a really nice system
that i'm looking forward to more
developments from that and other gene
circuit works and hopefully some
applications coming in the near future
so um i'm just going to to wrap up now
so yeah i just you know
uh you know
this project took a lot of work
identifying the
plant compatible parts to be able to
build up gene circuits for both the
crisper circuits as well as the uh
recombinase-based circuits then we've
been able to construct end and oil gates
and
we've also been able to construct a wide
range of repressive gates and you know
gates identify b-gate that makes
activation and
uh repression
and we were able to use split
recombinases to build synchronous
circuits where both uh input genes need
to be turned on at the same time in
order to uh allow for a recombination
event
uh so that just leaves me to thank um
you know the many people involved with
this particular thanks to ryan lester
for building like a really fantastic
environment to do research in
and supporting this project and you know
really believing in its potential and
also uh florence and patrick for being
two absolutely amazing students uh
working in the lab with me um you know
that they've been a real pleasure to
have
and um
just leaves me to thank you
thank you james that was really great
and extremely impressive for one in the
morning um
is anyone in this audience a question
okay uh there's one in the back i think
do you want to try speaking
of it
not really okay i'll catch it on the
microphone
i have a question um
margaret
margaret could i ask a question
yes hi this is ajim and this is great
job a very elegant and uh
uh
so i do have a quick question about of
two actually two questions
uh when is you know this technology is
based on
the philippis um
uh so how actually
you think the the completeness of that
uh
uh philippe works actually you know it's
when you express this enzyme it's all
sides in the plant cell will be like uh
you know
recombinant and loop out uh
those like
terminators and others
promoters
so you think it's complete uh uh just
like you say the zero or when or when
yes
um
it it it should be so uh it acts as a
tetramer to be able to cause a
recombination event between the two
and in our protoplast system
we generally have what we think is uh
hundreds of plasmids within a cell so i
don't think in the protoplast system it
is going to be complete because uh it's
got to target many many copies of the
the plasmid in a stable plant uh you
know in an ideal you know homozygote
single insertion line you'll have two
copies per cell so we think it must it's
likely to be much more effective um but
depending on what promoter you're using
as the input to drive flp or whichever
combination recombinant you're using
that will affect its uh um
how
able it is so with the line from the
heat shock we showed it looked like you
know all or most of the nuclei were uh
terminating but we've looked at some uh
constructs in stable lines where it does
look like it's more patchy
um
and so i think it depends on the line i
think it depends on the promoter um
so yeah so it yeah i think it can as a
recombine is it can it you know
recombine as long as the induction is
appropriate so we did a very potent heat
shock um but you know other input
promoters may be less effective at doing
that
okay that's great so another question is
uh you know relate to that the fl um
frt actually sequences
so i know atit uh
frt sequence
so frt sequence uh you know plant genome
is such huge actually genomes by
randomly you think there
are any such kind of
uh sequences
in the plant genome system uh that
occurred
in a larger scale of sort of deletion
and so on so forth
so yeah that's a really great question
and i think for arabidopsis and i have
to say i've not checked in detail for
flp and frt sites specifically um i
think it's unlikely our arabidopsis is
on the smaller side of the genome so if
we're dealing with something much larger
genome size maybe wheat for example then
it is much more likely we will have some
similar sequences however i think the
two recombination sites do have to be
fairly close together within the genome
for recombination to act so i know for
example for
lox p i think when i was working in moss
you know we figured out that it almost i
think you either almost never happened
or never happened where you had
recombination between chromosomes
and so you know at least being on the
same chromosome is a prerequisite and so
if we insert too close to each other
they will likely recombine but if
there's a you know a random sequence in
the genome that's similar it's unlikely
that that's going to recombine unless
they're very close together uh and that
may change with genome size but as the
genome size gets bigger it's also i
guess less likely you'd have too close
together so we're hoping that it'll be
of a minimal issue in most plant genomes
okay great
thank you i'm going to pass the mic over
to randy here in the audience
all right
designing the gates into the plant was
brilliant and um i have a question so
when designing um integrated circuits
one of the problems is straight
capacitance
and essentially what you have when when
one of the gates takes 48 hours instead
of 24 hours
is straight capacitance and i'm
wondering what you've thought about that
and how to look for it and how to change
that
yeah i think well
you know i i think your is a really good
point and
i think people are potentially going to
have issues with this all over
um
you know people building gene circuits
um
so
for example the alien play b date i
showed you
um
it took 64 hours for that to stabilize
and and show the logic uh that we
expected but if you check sooner then um
generally we were finding that the
inhibition
was uh slower than the activation
so
again i think uh
based on our
designs which you know this is the first
generation
we are seeing some of those issues and
some circuits will need more time in
order to stabilize and get to the the
the issue whether there's going to be
some cases where we can't get the logic
at all that we expect
i i
yeah that could well be true and um you
know with the crisper circuits we've
definitely been seeing some headaches
with some of the the logics so you know
i think that could be a factor
do you have any hypotheses of where the
capacitance coming from why the entirely
oh it's a good question um
[Music]
so
in our protoplast system i think you
know dynamics for
the recombination
you know based on distance between them
activity speed of the individual enzymes
or whether b3 is faster than flp i think
those are potential um factors i think
what's going to be more concerning is
moving into stable plants
um where we're adding in an extra
variable which is the promoter strength
so you know if you're using a cell type
specific promoter for one of the
recombinases and
you know a chemically inducible promoter
for the other then the the expression
level and the dynamics of that can also
factor into this so i think i think um
you know there's multiple things that
can be causing these issues does that
answer your question well you gave me
two good
yeah thank you very much james i have
like one shorter question so
um uh sometimes you know the the uh gene
networking implants is pretty complex
and sometimes the gene
expresses not like
follow that zero or one one or yes yes
or no or
uh more like
the minor in your logic so i have ever
seen those genes like they have like a
multiple or a lot of variation or some
robotness uh even though you just
change the conditions or
something like that it's still there so
it's still not closed or they only just
like reduce part of it or or something
like that so that that makes those
circuits make this
system like more
complex and complicated
sorry can you repeat the question yeah
basically my question is uh sometimes
the gene is not like uh that easily can
divide into 0 1 0 or 1 or yes or no or
open and close or those like binary
logic so it's like have ever met any
situation um
about like those genes are not those
follow that logic so how to build how
how are you gonna deal with that
yeah and i think
again this comes back to the idea we've
got to test a lot of things so if you're
trying to build for example you know so
so if we're talking about using
uh
an input promoter that is not you know
zero or one
to drive the input into the circuit then
it's gonna it could cause some problems
uh our hope is that the way these
recombination circuits will work is that
you might have an input promoter where
one is very lowly expressed another
could be very highly expressed
but then as long as they're causing the
recombination reaction which is a
one-off event then that should lock the
output gene into a particular expression
level because we're using this the
constitutive promoter often 35s are
acting too and so you're driving the
output so we're trying to
create it so that the
uh variation you know of the output gene
is dependent on things like insertion
site within the genome there's no way of
getting around that at the moment
but we can try and reduce some of the
noise from the you know the varying
expression levels from the input
promoters and i think for the
transcription factor circuits uh like
from what adele and jen have developed
i'm more concerned with the variation in
input promoter strengths and the
variation they're affecting that so
having very stochastic gene expression
uh in in those cases i think that could
cause some issues with those circuits
because they don't have that
analog to digital conversion that the
recombinant circuits allow does answer
your question
yeah yeah thanks yes it does i'm over
here
hopefully within camera though um so i
have a lot of ideas from your talk but i
guess just one broader question
um
is there any real world proof of concept
like translational outcome that you like
dream of testing now that you've set up
this logic framework
i
it's a great question uh because
one of the problems we have when we're
talking to people about trying to get
this translated or you know talking
about potential funding
is you know a lot of people a lot of
companies are very interested in well
you know
what is the one application and for us
it's like well we've built a toolkit
that can be used for almost any
application
um but yes i do have some particular
ones i'm very interested in looking into
and i heard about one recently involving
um controlling of gene expression after
harvest so you know so different
foods go off you know different crops go
off at different rates after harvest so
then you know we're talking things like
cabbage
and obviously putting them in the coal
you call the fridge helps prolong them
um now there are some ideas for how to
you know change gene expression that
could uh post harvest that could maybe
you know keep them healthier shelf
stable for longer but
do we really have a harvest specific
promoter
most of the promoters that are activated
during harvest and after harvest are
going to be um different stress response
pathways and i was speaking to some
people last week in the uk when i was um
traveling there about this very problem
and
you know i'm very excited by the
prospect of using you know
our recombination based gene circuits
where you have two different promoters
that are activated
during harvest both from different
pathways you know one could be a drought
pathway maybe one could be a very
different sort of stress pathway
they would normally never be expressed
at the same time so if you just
used one of them as a harvest marker it
would not be specific for harvest but if
you can combine both of them you could
make it have a specific marker and then
you could manipulate gene expression
post harvest and not during those other
stresses so i think that that's a
potential uh application but yeah there
are many more i think including sort of
pest resistance type things
yeah absolutely yeah so there's one more
question from yes i have one more
question for you
so um yeah this is perhaps uh not fair
to ask and this all your circuit as i
said is very elegant and but the problem
is
it's a one-time deal so when's turned on
then on when's turn off it's off
so there's no reversibility at all so
i'll tell you
how are you going to address this issue
yeah
uh yeah this this is something that
keeps coming up over and over again and
it's a very fair criticism these
circuits are very much about you know
one-time switches so i think there's a
few things so one is if you do need
reversibility over memory
then the transcription-based systems
like the crispr system and gen's
bacterial transcription practice system
they're where you want to go
in terms of us if you want like a
one-time like you want to turn something
on and then you want to turn it off
separately later i think those
that circuit design we could build a
more complicated three input circuit
that could do that where we combine
in activation and repression so again
that would be a one time done a one time
on one time off
but that's possible we haven't built
that yet but i you know i think that
would be quite straightforward
i think in terms of building a
reversible one using recombinases there
are a different family of recombinases
that
could be used for this there's some
issues with those but i think there is a
group working on that in america at the
moment so we may see some you know
publications on that in the future so
that would be another approach and then
finally where i would like to see the
field go long term would be
can we utilize these epigenetic systems
within plants you know like the
polychrome rehearsal complex like dna
methylation to build a semi-stable
you know repression system where we
could stably
methylate a region either the dna or
chromatin level and then reverse it with
a d-methylase
now the problem is that a lot of the
time we don't get good stable silencing
with the current epigenome modifying
tools that we have and that's true in
animals it's true to some extent in
plants and so
we need more testing in plants i think
is the main thing
and so i think maybe one day if we can
find the right cocktail of factors for
epigenome editing we could then move
away from recombinases to that but right
now the technology is just not there so
recombinases i think will be a very
useful inte you know stepping stone to
be able to to you know uh achieve that
great thank you james
okay let's thanks james again um and
please come visit us
next time
it would be a pleasure
thanks james
no thank you thank you ever so much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu